il y avait michel galabru il ya toujours
michel galabru mais il ya désormais jean
galabru auteur de théâtre qui fait jouer
son père en ce moment à paris un
vaudeville sur le thème de la politique
bon appétit messieurs se fige ou rémy
poissonnier gilbert usant chez les
galabru le théâtre est une affaire de
famille
un beau jour cette fois c'est le fiction
qui est l'auteur de la pièce et c'est
papa qui donnent la réplique
michel et jean allez je reste là pour
vous êtes fumeur pour un peu potache et
complice depuis le premier jour parce
que je sortais 2 de la clinique où il
est né même les intrus j'avais peur que
le beurre t2 du froid j'étais l'âge qui
la barre à 6 puis maintenant c'est un
miracle c'est des choses extraordinaires
ne papa comblé incarne sur scène un
ministre de la justice
fraîchement nommé l'histoire de mettre
en examen de la dumas renvoyons duras ou
non du barreau sous les verrous ça va
tellement vite à notre époque
la presse est averti avant noire du
balcon où j'écris en pense à lui je n'ai
entendu et en scène il fait des choses
que je n'avais pas pensé
alors ça c'est formidable mais dans une
famille loufoque et corrompu il n'est
pas facile de garder les mains propres à
l'arroseur arrosé
un personnage taillé sur mesure pour
michel galabru
as-tu voir que j'étais mort qui est
l'autorité va il a dû voir ça y
ressentir que je tiens peut un peu lâche
ton voir dieu adieu mes amis avoir
uniquement au royaume a pu aller tient à
les mater gratuit bercy ainsi qu'à voir
la première fois il accepte de l'argent
ça en main propre l'argent sale les
affaires galabru père et fils chahutent
nos hommes politiques et toute
ressemblance avec des personnages ayant
existé n'est pas fortuit voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal m